-♪ 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 ♪
-♪ Second ♪
♪ Summaries ♪
-Here we go.
-That's right.
-Hut!
This was a relationship
via the Internet.
In the '90s.
[ Buzzer ]
-Uh...
"Basic Instinct"?
I have no idea.
[ Buzzer ]
I didn't see that one either.
-If it was "Basic Instinct,"
I would've just gone like that.
-Oh, hey, whoa! Alright!
I didn't know.
[ Laughs ]
What was it?
-"You've Got Mail."
-Oh, "You've Got Mail."
I forgot about that one.
-Relationship via the Internet.
-That was a great one.
Oh! Ready?
Black guy, white guy, aliens.
Sunglasses, suits.
"Independence Day."
Oh, no! "Men in Black."
-Yes! That's it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I just watched
"Independence Day,"
and there is a white guy
and a black guy and aliens.
-The same plot. [ Laughs ]
Both of those movies
have the same plot.
Alright. Good.
Now, this round,
let's make it a little tougher.
We only have 3 seconds.
-Why?!
-Yes, because you need
to put people on edge.
-I'm already all the way
on edge.
-Got to keep the viewers, Andy.
Ready? 3 seconds.
-If I was any more on edge,
I'd be Bono.
Almost.
[ Laughter ]
It almost works!
-Nuh-uh.
Almost works.
-No, no, but Bono was never
on The Edge.
-If they were lovers.
I should've said
if they were lovers.
-The whole thing
is very complicated premise.
-You don't know
they're not lovers, dude.
[ Laughter ]
-You never know, man.
-Open your mind, Jimmy!
-Are you the one
on the tour bus?
You're the one that goes
on tour with them?
-They might've had a tryst,
Rattle and Hum tour.
-Yeah, which one --
which one rattled?
-Which one hummed?
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
3 seconds on the clock.
-Those guys don't pronounce T's.
"Ra'le and Hum 'our."
-[ Speaking gibberish ]
-Alright, here we go.
3 seconds on the clock
-Yep.
-The impossible game for burgers
that will never be bought.
-[ Laughs ] I will.
I'll buy them. I promise.
-I'm never gonna eat 10 burgers.
Alright. Here we go.
Hut!
[ Gruffly ]
This plane is goin' down!
-Nicolas Cage! Uh...
Some type of, uh...
one of those things
where the plane's going down.
Oh, wait! Uh -- uh --
"ConAir"!
-Yeah!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Wait.
-That was good.
-Wait, should I have been happy
or should I have been bummed?
-You're --
-If I wanted the burgers.
-You know, either way, you're
gonna get the burgers, right?
-That's not the point, man!
-I know. Sorry. Yeah, okay.
-But you should've
been bummed, probably.
-It's martial law
with this game.
-Yeah. Here we go. Ready?
3 seconds.
[ As Sylvester Stallone ]
Uh, tell you what, we'll get...
[ As Schwarzenegger ]
Get those explosions --
[ Buzzer ]
-Uh...
"Expendables"?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're rooting for each other
to win.
[ Both laughing ]
-It's the only one
they've been in together.
-I don't know.
Alright, final round.
Let's put one second
on the clock.
You got to keep people
on the edge, man.
-Who is this for, one second?
-This -- on the edge.
You got to keep people
on the edge of their seats.
-[ Sighs ]
-We're, you know,
riding the line.
You got to ride the line
sometimes, my man.
-Is it bad if they're so far
on the edge of their seat
that they leave?
-[ Laughs ]
They might fall on their floor.
But that's what you want.
-Alright.
-Mm-hmm.
-One second.
-If I get --
If I get this and you guess it,
does that mean
I get the burgers?
-I'm gonna buy burgers for your
crew on "Brooklyn 99."
-Oh, snap.
The heat is on.
But do I have to get it
for everyone on your show?
-Just play the game!
[ Laughter ]
You're doing the math
in your head.
You're like,
"There's a lot of Roots."
Yeah, like...
-[ Laughing ]
-There's at least eight Roots.
Yeah, yeah.
-That's some skrilla scratch,
Jimmy.
-"I'm a newlywed, man.
I'm saving up."
Alright.
-Alright.
Alright. Here we go.
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Exhales sharply ]
Aah!
I'm in the Cheerios!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-Honey Nut Cheerios?
I'm in the Cheerios --
"Honey, I Shrunk the Kids"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
The winner, Andy Samberg!
I'm buying!
-Come on!
-You ready?
-You got five. Yep.
-I'm a little kid, my parents
went on a trip,
I'm home by myself.
-"Home Alone"!
-Yes.
-That's good.
That's good, right there.
He's good.
He's a good guy to play with.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Okay.
White House blows up,
aliens, Fresh Prince.
-I know what it is,
but I don't know the name.
But it's Will Smith
and it's an alien movie.
"White House Down."
"White House"...
-"White House Down"?
-"White House Down."
-"White House Down"
is not a movie.
-It should have been.
-It's a good idea. Exactly.
-But I'm close. What is it?
-It is "Independence Day."
-That's right.
What's the one I'm thinking
of that was made later
where the White House
got attacked
and there was two that came out.
-That was the one.
-No, but two came out
at the same time
and they were both
kind of the same plot, right?
[ Audience shouting ]
-What was it?
-Jamie Foxx.
-"White House Down."
-Oh, it's a real movie?
-It was. It was more current,
and so I got confused.
But you did a great job, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, let's make it --
Let's make it a little tougher
for you, okay?
Now you're only going to have
3 seconds for this.
-3 seconds. Ready?
-Ready. Yeah.
-Okay.
You're money, baby.
-"Swingers"?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That was awesome.
You saying that was so cool.
That's like a dream I had once.
That's crazy.
You saying "You're money, baby"
to me, that's so awesome.
Alright, 3 seconds.
That was really cool.
Guys in jumpsuits shooting --
[ Buzzer ]
-Guys in jumpsuits shooting.
Yes.
Um...
Everyone knows that movie.
That's not the jump shooters
who shoot.
That's a different movie.
-No, yeah, yeah.
-This one would be called...
Uh, point b-- point --
"Point Blank"? No.
They're in the masks.
What is it?
-"Ghostbusters."
That was a good one, too.
That was great.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I got it.
-No, that was great.
It was probably my fault.
-No, no.
I know how to do it.
I know how to do it now.
Ready?
-Okay.
-Who ya gonna call?
-"Ghostbusters."
-Yeah.
-Okay. But you were great.
You were great.
-I wasn't that fast. Sorry.
-No, you were terrific.
-Oh, this one's only one second
on the clock.
[ Laughter ]
-Dinosaurs.
[ Buzzer ]
"Jurassic World."
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's the greatest!
You can't beat this guy.
You're a great guy
to play games with.
-But I'm learning that I have to
work a little bit
on my guessing.
I got room to grow.
I have to be tough on myself.
-This one, I'll be good at.
I promise.
-No, you're good already.
You did great already.
-Yeah.
Okay.
Uh, okay --
[ Buzzer ]
Wait, what?
I didn't even know...
When I put it down,
I have one second.
Okay. Ready?
Washboard abs.
-"Magic Mike."
-Yes! Yes!
-Yes!
Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-Go.
-Oh. Lightsabers. Droids.
-"Star Wars."
-Yep.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
-Wow. Great. Lightsaber.
-Thank you.
-Hey, this is good.
-That really just came to me.
-We make a good team.
-I was excited.
-Alright. Here we go.
-Okay. Oh, I have to guess.
-Here we go. Ready?
-Yeah.
-Singing. Los Angeles.
-"La La Land."
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-We just talked about it.
Alright...
Hey. We're fantastic.
We should go on the road.
-Ooh, don't jinx us.
Don't jinx us.
We had one good round.
-Here we go.
-Oh, this one -- No.
All -- We're all one team.
Yeah.
-No one loses?
-No one loses here.
For this round, though, we're
gonna make it a little tougher.
We're only gonna have
3 seconds.
-Oi.
-Okay?
3 seconds to describe the plot.
Let's put 3 seconds
on the clock.
You are up first. Ready?
-I don't see the clock. Okay.
-Go.
There is no --
-Oh, there's basketball, Shaq,
and it's a cartoon.
-"Space Jam"?
-Yes!
Oh, you're so good!
Wait.
Was Shaq not in that?
-No. First of all --
-I never saw it!
-First of all,
Shaq is not even in "Space Jam."
-He's not?
-No!
You're thinking
of Michael Jordan.
Jim.
-You got it. You got it.
-I know.
-There's no losers here.
-Shaq.
-I don't --
But he was in something.
-"Shazam."
-Fine. Thank you.
-"Kazaam."
"Kazaam."
-Thank you.
Alright. Here we go.
-Ay, yi yi.
-3 seconds.
3 seconds on the fake clock.
-We're friends,
so we're doing this.
-Yes.
-I know!
-Yeah, Shaq was probably not in
this movie, but you never know.
-Maybe.
-Alright. Ready?
-Yeah.
[As George Bailey] "Merry
Christmas! Merry Christmas!
Oh --"
-"It's A Wonderful Life."
-Alright. Does that count?
Judges say yeah.
-[ Bell dings ]
-Thank you.
That was really good.
-It wasn't good.
-That was really good.
-Was that not a good
Jimmy Stewart?
-It was so good that
it scared me and panicked me
because I knew that
I should know it immediately.
"Yeah."
-I'm not lying.
-"Merry Christmas!"
-It was so dead-on.
-You've done Jimmy Stewart.
You've done "Harvey."
-I did "Harvey."
I tried not to do Jimmy Stewart.
-I know, but --
-Geez! Honestly.
You know what?
Just play. Just play.
-Shaq wasn't --
Really? Shaq cartoon?
-For round three,
we each have one second.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I get 60 seconds --
or one second on the clock?
This is awful.
-For round three,
we do have one second
on the clock.
-I can't even read it
in that time!
-Yes, you can.
-And I didn't cheat!
-I don't do that.
I didn't cheat, either.
I don't know
what they are, either.
That's the fun of the game.
-It just scares me so much.
-This is a fun game. Ready?
-It's not anymore.
-One second.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
-Go!
-♪ Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun ♪
-"Jaws"!
-Thank you!
[ Bell dings ]
Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stop screaming.
-They always ask
if I want to play a game here,
and I'm always like,
"Yes, I love playing games!"
And then I just --
It's just awful.
-You get stressed. Alright.
-Oh, my God.
I said,
"Anything but that egg game."
That's what I always say.
I'm not putting an egg
on my face.
-Why? That game's fun.
-Metaphorically, I will.
But I don't want to
have to bathe before I go
to dinner after this.
You know what I mean?
-But it's fun.
-You get so dirty
doing that egg game,
and it's sticky.
-How do you know?
You haven't played the game.
-I've watched.
-Here we go. One second.
-One second.
-I'm gonna look at you
in case you have to gesture.
-We've gotten every one so far.
This has never happened.
We got some chemistry here, man.
-Yeah.
-Ready? One second.
-Okay.
-Tornado. Cow. Uh --
-[ Buzzer ]
-"Twister"!
-Yeah! It was!
It was "Twister"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-I feel like...
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
...but I don't care.
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jim Parsons!
[ Laughter ]
-It's an animation. Animation.
It's about a snowman.
And there's a girl.
It's a Disney movie.
[ Buzzer ]
-"Forever."
No. What's that one? "Frozen."
-"Frozen." Yes!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Mumbles ]
-It started with an F.
-Yeah.
Is "Forever" a movie?
-"Forever." Yeah. No.
-We should make that one.
That's a good animation.
-Okay. Now I go?
-You take the first card. Yeah.
I'm not looking. First card.
-Okay. Okay.
Um -- A, um --
Wait, wait. Don't count yet.
-No -- No, not yet.
Now it's -- And go. Count.
-Okay.
A hack screenwriter in L.A.
Car dispossessed.
Repossessed.
Winds up an old lady.
[ Buzzer ]
-"Psycho"?
-No.
-Winds up as an old lady?
-No. With an old woman.
They met at
a chimpanzee's funeral.
It's black-and-white.
-Oh.
-And it doesn't end well
for him.
-Oh, he's floating in the pool
at the beginning?
-That's right.
-Is it "Sunset Boulevard"?
-Yes.
-Oh.
-[ Bell dings ]
-Okay.
-I don't know anything
about the --
-The chimpanzee?
Yeah, that's a whole thing.
-That's not the whole thing at
all! What are you talking about?
It's not a monkey --
I'm thinking of a monkey movie.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's really weird.
It's really weird.
-Yeah, I gotta watch that again.
I don't remember that.
-It's really strange.
-It's awesome. Alright.
What happened?
Oh, yeah, this one -- Yeah.
This one, we make it
a little tougher.
[ Laughs ]
We only have 3 seconds to do it.
-Alright.
-We can do this.
-So I'll get it,
and I'm gonna say, "Go."
And then you have 3 seconds.
Alright. Ready?
Go. Spinning house
falls on the Wicked Witch.
-Oh. "Wizard of Oz."
-Yeah.
Come on! That's how we do it.
Confidence.
It's just the confidence.
I went right in there like that.
-I mean, really.
-Confidence. Alright. Yeah.
-Okay. Okay.
-You say, "Go,"
and you got 3 seconds.
-Okay. You ready?
-Yeah.
Soft-hearted, tough guy in love
with the hero's wife
and everybody's noble.
[ Buzzer ]
-This is -- What? No,
you're too much of a director.
This is like --
[ Laughter ]
What the hell
are you talking about?
The hell are you talking about?!
A hero falls in love
with a noble person? What the --
Come on! Tell me a monkey's
in the movie --
-Soft-hearted tough guy.
-A soft-hearted tough guy.
-Falls in love
with this hero's wife, right?
-Okay.
-And he fights Nazis.
-Ooh.
-And everybody's noble
by the end.
-"The Sound of Music."
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
That was a great Nazi movie.
The Nazis are running around.
They're singing songs.
-No. Come on. Come on.
Colonel Strasser.
-He was Colonel Strasser?
-Black-and-white. No,
he was not. Colonel Strasser.
-Joking. I was joking. Hello?
-He ran a club in North Africa.
-Oh, he ran a club.
"Play it again, Sam."
"Casablanca."
-That's it. Yeah.
Good.
Well, that was rough
because I didn't get
"fight Nazis" in there.
-You only have 3 seconds, Marty.
[ Laughter ]
-My movies are long.
What can I tell you?
That's why your movies --
That's why your movies are long.
Here. The last round.
One second.
-Alright.
There's only one --
You have one word
to describe it.
This is mine.
You wanna do mine?
-No, you do yours.
-Alright.
-I can't see anymore.
What is that? Oh. Okay.
-Here's that one.
-Okay.
-Ready for this?
One second for this one.
Go. Bear fight.
-"Revenant."
-Yes! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I knew you'd get that one!
I love it, I love it.
Alright. That's great.
Alright. Good.
-Okay.
-You want to try?
-Yeah.
-You got one second.
Okay. You ready?
-Yes.
-Rich man misses sled.
-Oh! Oh, my gosh!
-[ Buzzer ]
That's great. Wait, wait.
Don't tell me.
Don't tell me. Don't tell me.
-Rich man misses sled!
It's his sled. It's the thing.
Oh, my gosh!
"Citizen Kane"!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Laughter ]
Ah! Martin Scorsese, everybody!